whether you love it hate it or never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners up the portland oregon
health inspector who threw the book at
this seven year old little girl busted
for selling lemonade without a permit
reminds us of the Clayton California
mayor who cracked down on this
three-year-old for selling vegetables in
2008 the mayor shut down her unlicensed
veggie stand I did wish that everyone
would follow the rule but there's only
one nanny of the month and this time
it's quincy illinois police chief rob
copeley whose officers arrested this man
who was keeping drunk drivers off the
streets it's a great service it's a
needed service but the laws the law and
although Jonathan shona case gives
drinkers free rides home from bars he
does accept tips and that violates the
city's taxi ordinance quincy police
officers set up a sting operation to
catch jonah case in the act of violating
that city ordinance come on chief don't
your cops have anything better to do
we've got a lot better things just put
it as part of our job check back next
month for more examples of busybodies
minding your own business